Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain an Australian
romantic comedy film called “Long Story
Short.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie starts at a New Year's Eve party.
The protagonist is named Teddy, a guy who
doesn’t value time and is a massive procrastinator.
He arrives at the party when the countdown
to the new year begins.
He sees his girlfriend on the other end and
kisses her right at twelve o’clock.
But Teddy soon realizes that he is kissing
a stranger wearing the exact same dress as
his girlfriend.
He quickly draws back and apologies to the
lady who excuses his genuine mistake.
Out of embarrassment, he buys her a drink
which she happily accepts.
The woman introduces herself as Leanne.
As they two talk, Teddy begins to cough and
shake violently.
It turns out that she had eaten something
with nuts before Teddy kissed her which triggered
his allergy.
She brings him to the side and tries to calm
him down.
Right then, Teddy’s girlfriend Becka approaches
them and sees that he is having an allergic
reaction.
They get an EpiPen from somewhere and save
Teddy.
After that incident, Teddy and Leanne start
to date.
They are a happy couple for the next four
years but being the procrastinator he is,
Teddy proposes to her only on their fifth
year together.
After the proposal, the couple visits Teddy’s
dad’s grave.
They tell him how the proposal went while
an old lady listens from afar.
When Leanne leaves Teddy for some time, the
old woman congratulates him.
She asks him when the wedding is and Teddy
replies he hasn’t thought about it yet.
The woman senses his carelessness with time
and questions what he would do if a year went
by in a minute and he didn’t have enough
time to live his life.
Her question makes Teddy uncomfortable but
the woman doesn’t stop there.
She tells him that she has a perfect wedding
gift for him.
By then, Leanne returns and greets the woman.
As they chat, the woman mentions that Teddy
said their wedding is in two weeks.
Leanne gets very excited and hugs Teddy, so
he goes along with the lie.
Two weeks after the incident, they get married.
At their wedding, Teddy’s best friend Sam
gives a speech about their friendship and
jokes about his habits with time.
The couple is beyond happy when they return
to their newly bought home.
They plan to unbox their belongings and start
decoration from the next day.
For a few minutes, Leanne goes into the bathroom
to change and Teddy goes through their wedding
presents.
One of them is a tiny house plant which they
agree to name Groot.
But the one that catches Teddy’s eye is
a box that says “Do not open for ten years”.
He opens the box and sees a tin can inside.
The can also has something inside it which
Teddy plans to open with a can opener.
However, Leanne comes out of the bathroom,
so he gets distracted.
The night ends and when Teddy wakes up the
following morning, he is shocked to see the
bedroom fully decorated.
He jokes saying that Leanne really did everything
before breakfast.
But things get weirder when he walks out of
the room to their fully colored and decorated
home.
The house plant Groot has grown overnight
as well.
Confused, he turns around to see a pregnant
Leanne standing behind him.
Teddy laughs thinking that it is a prank but
little does he know, he has time-traveled
a year into the future.
Teddy inspects her belly and registers that
she is actually pregnant.
He questions what is going on because they
got married just yesterday but Leanne thinks
he is just playing with her.
She asks for her one-year anniversary present
which makes Teddy believe he might have Alzheimer’s.
Leanne ignores him and hands him his present.
Teddy is still very confused so Leanne asks
him to lie down for a while.
As he lays on the bed, things around him start
to fade.
In the next second, a year passes.
Teddy wakes up and runs into Leanne who is
clearly not pregnant.
He laughs thinking that he had just had a
bad dream but as they chat, a baby’s cry
is heard from the other room.
Teddy looks around and sees many pictures
of him and Leanne that he clearly doesn’t
remember taking.
But he is even more surprised after seeing
their daughter Tallulah.
He holds her for the first time and feels
magical.
After arguing about Tallulah’s name, he
tells Leanne he might have traveled through
time, but she just laughs it off.
Teddy then inquires about the past year only
to find out that he has been away from home
for work half of the time.
Then, Leanne asks him to quit his job and
pursue photography, which he actually wants
to do in life.
Teddy is surprised that he hasn’t started
photography even after two years of marriage.
Moreover, he never took Leanne on a honeymoon
because of his habit of procrastination.
Teddy feels guilty for all this so he calls
his friend Sam and asks him to come to his
house the same day next year with an anniversary
present.
Following that, he places an orange in Groot’s
pot to see if he will actually time travel.
The time changes again and now it is their
third anniversary.
The orange has rotten and dried and Groot
has grown exponentially bigger.
Sam arrives outside confused about a reminder
on his phone.
Teddy hugs him and asks him for the anniversary
present.
But Sam has brought a little pony thinking
that he meant a “nursery present”.
Teddy explains everything that is going on
to Sam but he doesn’t believe him.
Upon insisting, Sam associates the incident
to the movie Groundhog Day, and asks Teddy
to make his life perfect in order to end the
loop.
Teddy asks him to set a reminder for the same
day next year and leaves.
At home, he meets little Tallulah and is mad
that “daddy” wasn’t her first word.
Leanne says that he is rarely home with her
because of work.
Teddy also finds out that he and Leanne are
going to couples therapy because of marital
problems.
He reads a letter that the current Teddy has
written to Leanne where he says that she should
stop pursuing her dream to become a writer.
Leanne reads it too and accuses him of being
jealous because he never pursued photography.
Teddy is disappointed in himself seeing how
much he has changed in the years.
In the very next second, another year goes
by as well.
He calls for Leanne but she doesn’t answer.
Following that, Sam arrives at the house and
informs Teddy that he and Leanne are in a
trial separation, meaning they have decided
to spend time away from each other for a while.
He quickly calls Leanne and wishes her a happy
anniversary trying to get his life back together
and end the time travel.
But she refuses to meet him when he invites
her.
Teddy opens the fridge to get a drink and
the time changes again.
This time, he walks to the other room and
kisses a woman thinking she is Leanne but
it turns out to be his ex-girlfriend Becka.
She tells him that they have been seeing each
other for a few months now and that Leanne
and he are still in a trial separation.
Becka used to be married but has gotten a
divorce.
As Teddy tries to get her out of the house,
Leanne knocks on the door.
He hides Becka in the balcony and lets Leanne
in.
She tells him that she misses him and that
they should end the separation and get back
together.
Teddy is overjoyed to hear this and kisses
her but she notices Becka’s undergarments
on the couch.
She registers that Teddy has been seeing someone
else and asks for a divorce.
Teddy tries to calm her down but Leanne storms
out.
After that, Becka sarcastically offers Teddy
a divorce lawyer.
Before making her leave, he asks her not to
pick his phone calls or answer his texts if
he tries to contact her again.
When Teddy turns around, Becka is in the kitchen
in different clothes.
An entire year has passed again.
He finds out that he and Leanne are still
separated and Becka has moved in with him.
Teddy quickly calls Sam and asks him to meet
outside.
Following that, he tells Becka that he is
still in love with Leanne.
Becka, too, tells him that she loves her ex-husband
and has made the biggest mistake of her life
separating from him.
The two bond with each other and decide to
end their relationship.
A while later, Sam arrives in his sports car
and picks Teddy up.
As they talk, Teddy gets to know that Sam
has been diagnosed with cancer and there is
very little chance of his survival.
Teddy is left speechless and makes Sam promise
he will be alive when he returns the next
year.
The two share an emotional conversation before
Teddy goes to meet Leanne in her new home.
Leanne asks him if he signed the divorce papers.
Teddy is taken aback by the comment.
He registers that she has filed for divorce
and he has been refusing to sign the papers
for the past year.
He asks her to get back together with him
but Leanne urges him to go away knowing that
he is with Becka.
As she closes the door on him, the time changes
again to one year later.
Teddy accidentally falls into Tallulah’s
pool and is approached by Leanne’s new boyfriend
Patrick.
He freaks out and starts insulting him only
to realize that Leanne is finally happy with
a man.
He is also informed that Leanne lost her wedding
ring in the ocean.
Seeing her enjoy life again, he signs the
divorce papers and has an emotional breakdown
in front of Patrick.
To cheer Teddy up a little, Leanne allows
him to take her dog for a walk.
Teddy and the dog go to the beach where he
sits thinking about life.
A year passes in some seconds and Teddy is
seen with a full beard.
He is still on the beach with the dog when
he notices a chocolate bar with nuts lying
on the ground.
He thinks of eating it to commit suicide but
stops when a seven-year-old Tallulah calls
him.
She is happily making sandcastles behind him.
Teddy is in shock to see his little girl all
grown up.
Talking to her gives him a reason to live.
He takes her back to Leanne after the playdate.
He and Leanne have a good chat for a long
time.
After she goes inside, Teddy remembers it’s
their anniversary and knocks on the door.
Right then the time fast forwards again to
a year later.
Teddy’s beard is gone and he has glasses
now.
Leanne is not in the house so he calls Sam
again.
But to his surprise, the operator says that
the number doesn’t exist anymore.
Teddy quickly goes to his social media and
sees pictures of them at the hospital while
Sam was battling cancer.
Eventually, he finds out that Sam has died
in the past year.
Filled with grief at the loss, he visits Sam’s
grave.
While talking to the grave, the old woman
from earlier approaches him.
She tells him that she knows he has aged ten
years in the past hour.
Teddy, in shock, questions her what is going
on.
The woman claims she gave him the power to
live life in snapshots.
She further explains that she was about to
marry a man in her twenties when she met a
stranger who gave her the same gift.
She, too, saw her life in snapshots and as
a result, didn’t marry the man.
Instead, she married the woman she loved.
Still confused, Teddy calls the woman a lesbian
wizard who has cast a curse on him.
She clarifies that there is a way to turn
time back and live life with the knowledge
he has gained.
Teddy remembers the tin can he got as a gift
for his wedding.
He quickly rushes to Leanne’s and asks her
if she still has it.
Leanne brings the box out and also informs
Teddy that she and Patrick are broken up.
She reveals that Patrick thought she was still
in love with Teddy.
Teddy suddenly figures out what is inside
the can and hands it to Leanne as their tenth-anniversary
present.
Leanne opens it and finds her wedding ring
inside.
Teddy then proposes to her again saying that
they both love each other and life to too
short to not be with the person you love.
Leanne states that it is so much more complicated
than that but eventually agrees to marry him.
Suddenly, the time changes to the day after
Teddy’s wedding.
He wakes up to Leanne wishing him a happy
first day as her husband.
He hugs her tightly and rushes to book their
honeymoon.
Overjoyed with emotions, he calls his boss
and quits his job saying that he will be a
photographer.
Next, he calls Sam and asks him to go for
a cancer screening every year on the same
day and threatens to drag him to the hospital
if he doesn’t.
He then runs to the magical can with an intention
of giving it to Becka, who he knows needs
it.
The movie ends as Teddy tells Leanne that
they can do everything they like in life right
at that moment.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.